This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Five steps to keep in a defecting population. Step one. Build a 12-foot reinforced concrete wall. There was a wall. Step two. Build a second wall right next to it. Creating a no-man's land in between. Then there was a 10-20 meter wide strip of land, which Then there was a 10-20 meter wide strip of land, which there was absolutely nothing. Das Niemannsland. That was sprayed with chemicals that not even grass could grow.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。阻止人口流失的五个步骤。第一步：建造一堵12英尺高的钢筋混凝土墙。墙建好了。第二步：在紧挨着它的地方再建一堵墙。在两墙之间创造一片无人区。然后是一条10到20米宽的土地，那里什么都没有。这就是“无人区”。上面喷洒了化学药剂，连草都长不出来。
And it was raked every day that you could see the slightest clue that there was an escape this time. Step 3. Build a narrow road for vehicles of the secret police. Distazi, step 4. Add electrified barbed wire. And also, step 5. Signal wires. Signal wires.
而且每天都会进行平整，这样一旦有人逃跑，就能看到哪怕最细微的痕迹。第三步：为秘密警察“斯塔西”修建一条窄路。第四步：增加带电的铁丝网。还有第五步：信号线。信号线。
That if you touch it immediately in one of the watchtowers, there was the alarm ringing. At its peak, the Berlin Wall was 100 miles long. Today, only about a mile is left standing. Compared with other famous walls in history, this wall had a pretty short lifespan. The Great Wall of China has been around for 2500 years, so have the walls of ancient Babylon. Although it's most famous part, the Ishtar Gate is actually in a museum in Berlin. This is Daniel Gross.
如果你触碰它，其中一个岗楼就会立即响起警报。在鼎盛时期，柏林墙全长100英里。今天，只剩下大约一英里。与历史上其他著名的墙相比，这堵墙的寿命相当短。中国长城已经存在了2500年，古巴比伦的城墙也是如此。尽管它最著名的部分——伊什塔尔城门，实际上在柏林的一家博物馆里。我是丹尼尔·格罗斯。
But even though the wall dividing Berlin into East and West was only up for 30 years, it had a huge impact on the psyche of the city. It broke families in two. Now, let's remember how it got here. In 1945, Berlin was the fallen Nazi capital. The weary victors could agree on two things. One, Hitler was bad. Two, Germany needed a big change.
尽管将柏林一分为二的这堵墙只存在了30年，但它对这座城市的心理产生了巨大的影响。它让家庭支离破碎。现在，让我们回顾一下它是如何出现的。1945年，柏林是纳粹战败后的首都。疲惫的胜利者们在两件事上达成了共识。第一，希特勒是坏的。第二，德国需要彻底的改变。
After that, they did not agree on very much. Berlin was carved up into two sectors, with Western countries controlling the west of the city and the Soviet Union controlling the east. West Berlin had a booming post-war economy, but life was tougher in East Berlin. So in the decade that followed, more than 2 million people fled from East to West, East Germany was losing its most skilled workers, as they sought jobs and a reunite with their families across the border. And East Germany was losing face with every East Berliner who chose to defect.
在那之后，他们在很多事情上无法达成一致。柏林被划分为两个区域，西方国家控制城市西部，苏联控制东部。西柏林有着繁荣的战后经济，但东柏林的生活却更加艰难。因此，在随后的十年里，超过200万人从东部逃往西部。东德正在失去最熟练的工人，因为他们寻求工作并与边境另一边的家人团聚。而且，每有一位东柏林人选择叛逃，东德就丢一次脸。
And that's why, in 1961, East Germany closed its border to West Berlin with a wall. But this isn't a story about the design of the Berlin wall. This is a story about one design to get through it, or really underneath it. Ralph Kabish was there. The tunnel had a diameter of less than one square meter. We had to save space. The less we excavate, the better it was. You couldn't sit, you were laying on your back or on your front, and with the feet we were driving the spade into the front face. You couldn't dig for more than two hours than you are really dead.
这就是为什么在1961年，东德用一堵墙关闭了通往西柏林的边界。但这并不是一个关于柏林墙设计的故事。这是一个关于如何穿过它，或者更确切地说是从它下面穿过的设计故事。拉尔夫·卡比什当时就在那里。隧道的直径不到一平方米。我们必须节省空间。挖掘得越少越好。你不能坐着，只能仰卧或俯卧，用脚把铲子蹬进前方的土里。你挖不了两个小时，否则真的会累死。
dick for more than 12 hours than you are really dead. In 1964, Ralph was 21, a student at the free university of Berlin. Ralph was studying civil engineering. At school he made a lot of models and did a lot of math. But he hadn't really ever built anything. And like virtually everyone in West Berlin, Ralph knew and was related to people in East Berlin. Parents, brothers, sisters, cousins, classmates, how could they get to the West? You couldn't have jumbled with all. You couldn't have fly over it. It was the only way. Dig a tunnel.
挖超过12个小时，你就真的死定了。1964年，拉尔夫21岁，是柏林自由大学的学生。拉尔夫学习的是土木工程。在学校里，他做了很多模型，做了很多数学计算。但他从来没有真正建造过什么东西。而且像西柏林几乎所有人一样，拉尔夫认识东柏林的人，也有亲戚在那里。父母、兄弟、姐妹、堂表亲、同学，他们怎么才能去西部？你不可能翻过那堵墙。你不可能飞越它。这是唯一的办法：挖一条隧道。
In 1964, Westerners could still visit the east if they were in good standing with the Eastern Government. That year Ralph took a trip with his parents and sister, from the west to the east, to visit extended family. My cousin approached my sister and me and said, can you do something for me? I must get out of here. Rumors had been going around of tunnels popping up beneath the city. So when I get back to Berlin, I had an idea who was involved here. And I approached him. We were living together in the students' dormitory.
1964年，如果西方人与东部政府关系良好，他们仍然可以访问东部。那一年，拉尔夫和他的父母及妹妹从西部前往东部，探望远房亲戚。我的堂兄找到我和我妹妹说，你们能为我做点什么吗？我必须离开这里。当时关于城市地下出现隧道的传言四起。所以当我回到柏林时，我大概知道是谁参与其中。我联系了他。我们当时住在一起，在学生宿舍里。
I approached him, I asked him, and four days later, it was in the tunnel. Now to be clear, the kids were tumbling from west to east. They were tumbling into communist east Berlin. Ralph was led to a defunct bakery along the border. It had closed because too many of its customers were stuck in the east. Near the bakery's entrance, you could actually see East German guard towers looming over the wall. And in that bakery, young Berliners were tearing into the ground, trying to dig a tunnel
我联系了他，问了他，四天后，我就在隧道里了。现在要说明的是，这些孩子是从西向东挖。他们正挖向共产主义的东柏林。拉尔夫被带到边境附近一家倒闭的面包店。它倒闭是因为太多的顾客被困在东部。在面包店入口附近，你实际上可以看到东德的岗楼在墙上若隐若现。在那家面包店里，年轻的柏林人正在挖掘地面，试图挖一条隧道
under the wall and into East Berlin. We were digging vertically down until we got to the ground water table. If you don't want your tunnel to flood, stay above the water table. And from there, we said, okay, half meter above the ground water table. If you don't want your tunnel to flood, stay above the water table. And from there, we said, okay, half meter above the ground water table, we dig for it, straight for it, horizontally. Very simple. Very simple in theory.
穿过墙下进入东柏林。我们垂直向下挖掘，直到到达地下水位。如果你不想让隧道被淹，就得保持在地下水位之上。从那里，我们说，好吧，在地下水位上方半米处，我们直接水平挖掘。非常简单。理论上非常简单。
In practice, Berlin is a nightmare underneath the surface. The city is a swamp. The ground is so wet and sandy that to this day, construction workers have to pump water out of Berlin's soil in order to build new subway tunnels. They even use mobile refrigeration units to freeze the ground solid in trouble spots. But the soil over by the bakery happened to be perfect for tunneling. Because here was the geologic soil is consisting mainly of clay. That means if you dig there a hole in it, it is self-supporting, whereas sand collapses.
实际上，柏林地表之下是一场噩梦。这座城市是一片沼泽。地面非常潮湿且多沙，以至于直到今天，建筑工人在建造新的地铁隧道时，仍必须将水从柏林的土壤中抽出来。他们甚至使用移动制冷装置在困难地段将地面冻结成固体。但面包店那边的土壤恰好非常适合挖掘。因为这里的地质土壤主要由粘土组成。这意味着如果你在那里挖一个洞，它是自支撑的，而沙子会坍塌。
And this is one of very, very few areas in and around Berlin where you have such solid formation. That made it for us so interesting. Of course, Stazzi knew it. So from an engineering perspective, this bakery seemed like the perfect place to dig a tunnel. But strategically, it seemed like a terrible choice. This was the spot where right after the wall was built, some Germans in the east tried to jump out of their apartment windows into the west, which made the eastern
这是柏林及其周边地区极少数拥有如此坚固地层的区域之一。这让我们觉得非常有趣。当然，斯塔西也知道这一点。所以从工程角度来看，这家面包店似乎是挖隧道的完美地点。但从战略上讲，这似乎是一个糟糕的选择。就在柏林墙建成后，一些东德人试图从公寓窗户跳进西部，这使得东部
government extra careful about security. During the lifespan of the wall, five people died on this stretch of border. So we're talking about a bunch of 20-somethings digging a tunnel, the length of one and a half football fields, with a garden spade and a wheelbarrow under one of the most fortified borders on earth. Ralph was actually joining the second tunnel that this group had dug. The first tunnel had stretched nearly 500 feet, a six-month effort. The day they reached the backyard of an apartment building in the east, it was snowing.
政府对安全格外小心。在柏林墙存在的期间，有五个人死在这段边境线上。所以我们说的是一群20多岁的年轻人，用园艺铲和独轮车，在地球上防御最严密的边境之一下面，挖一条一个半足球场长的隧道。拉尔夫实际上是加入了这个小组挖掘的第二条隧道。第一条隧道延伸了近500英尺，耗时六个月。当他们到达东部一栋公寓楼的后院时，天正在下雪。
And because the air inside the tunnel was warmer than outside, it left a small circle of melted snow. Which basically told the Stasi, you who there's a tunnel over here. Within a few hours, the Stasi found out and flooded the tunnel with water. But Ralph Cabish says that being 20 years old and free Berlin, they were all naive enough to try again. One of the student leaders, Wolfgang Fuchs, proposed a bit of reverse psychology. Wolfgang, it was a really smart guy, said, you know, the Stasi, we fool them. They would not even dream about that we use the same location for another tunnel. So idiotic nobody could be. And it worked. And that was a tunnel Ralph started working on in the
因为隧道里的空气比外面暖和，它留下了一个融化雪的小圆圈。这基本上告诉了斯塔西，嘿，这里有一条隧道。几个小时内，斯塔西就发现了，并用水淹没了隧道。但拉尔夫·卡比什说，作为20岁的自由柏林人，他们都天真得足以再试一次。其中一位学生领袖沃尔夫冈·福克斯提出了一个反向心理学的方法。沃尔夫冈，他是个非常聪明的人，说，你知道，斯塔西，我们愚弄他们。他们做梦也不会想到我们会用同一个地点挖另一条隧道。没人会那么蠢。结果成功了。这就是拉尔夫在
summer of 1964. The bakery where the tunnel started was in the basement of an apartment building full of retirees. A group of 20 or so students going in and out all the time would have been suspicious, so they had to be stealthy. They could only come in and out every couple weeks. In other words, they had to live there. The bakery had become a makeshift home. They slept in military cots and warmed up canned food on a little electric stove that ran on borrowed electricity.
1964年夏天开始工作的隧道。隧道开始的面包店位于一栋住满退休人员的公寓楼地下室。一群20个左右的学生进进出出肯定会引起怀疑，所以他们必须隐蔽。他们每隔几周才能进出一次。换句话说，他们必须住在那里。面包店成了临时的家。他们睡在行军床上，用借来的电在小电炉上加热罐装食品。
Of course we needed more power than a retired couple is using normally. The most stupid man of a power company would say, my goodness, normally they pay about $20 a month, yeah? And now they consume for 200. How come? So one of our friends managed to get to the power supply cable before it went into the distribution board, before the power was metered and registered to the various apartments. The windows were painted white on the inside to minimize suspicion, but maximize lighting. In the bakery's storage room, flower and salt and sugar had been replaced with heaps and heaps of
当然，我们需要比一对退休夫妇正常使用的更多的电力。电力公司最笨的人也会说，天哪，他们平时一个月付20美元，对吧？现在他们消耗了200美元。怎么回事？所以我们的一位朋友设法在电源线进入配电盘之前，在电力被计量并登记到各个公寓之前，接通了电源。窗户内侧被漆成白色，以减少怀疑，同时最大限度地增加照明。在面包店的储藏室里，面粉、盐和糖已经被成堆的
dirt. And when they needed fresh supplies like tools, baked beans, spare parts, tape, soda, that was where Ralph came in. I had a job as a student on the weekend to deliver drinks, home service. I had a small Volkswagen bully, like a bus or station, a bigger station wagon. And that was of course perfect camouflage, yeah, for bringing in tools, spare parts, cans, bread, drinks. In these boxes, we are normally the bottles were. How much soil do you think you moved in total?
泥土所取代。当他们需要工具、烘焙豆、备件、胶带、苏打水等新鲜补给时，这就是拉尔夫发挥作用的时候了。我当时是一名学生，周末做饮料配送的家庭服务工作。我有一辆大众小巴，像公共汽车或旅行车，一辆更大的旅行车。那当然是完美的伪装，用来运送工具、备件、罐头、面包、饮料。在这些盒子里，通常装的是瓶子。你认为你总共搬运了多少土？
The shaft going down that had a size of 2x2 meters. 12 meters, that is, that's about to be 4, that's already almost 50 cubic meters. Yeah, and then, 145. I never thought about it. Never thought about it. Could be close to 200 cubic meters. Yeah.
向下的竖井大小为2x2米。12米深，那大约是4，已经快50立方米了。是的，然后是145。我从来没想过。从来没想过。可能接近200立方米。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. Craftmanship. Yeah. Yeah. An 18-wheeler truck can haul about 50 cubic meters. Crosper Chip. An 18-wheeler truck can haul about 50 cubic meters. So wheelbarrow after wheelbarrow, through the summer and into the autumn, roughness friends scraped and carved and heaved enough dirt to fill 418-wheeler big rigs.
是的。是的。手艺。是的。是的。一辆18轮大卡车大约能装50立方米。所以一车又一车，从夏天一直到秋天，拉尔夫和他的朋友们铲、挖、搬运的泥土足以装满4辆18轮大卡车。
All the while worried, the stasi would spot them, coming in and out, or detect them with special acoustic sensors. Fall 1964. They finally reached the east. They'd aimed for a basement, just like last time, but again they miscalculated. The one who was on duty on the front face of the tunnel came back with a little plant. He saw, oh, there are roots, and that was grass. They hadn't noticed that the border zone sloped slightly downward, which is forgivable, given the fact that they couldn't properly survey the land. But this time they were lucky. They had come up inside an abandoned shed.
在此期间，他们一直担心斯塔西会发现他们进进出出，或者用特殊的声学传感器探测到他们。1964年秋天。他们终于到达了东部。他们像上次一样瞄准了一个地下室，但再次算错了。在隧道前方负责的人带回了一小株植物。他看到，哦，有根，那是草。他们没有注意到边境地带略微向下倾斜，考虑到他们无法对土地进行适当的测量，这是可以原谅的。但这次他们很幸运。他们出现在一个废弃的棚子里。
Soon after the tunnelers left the shed, they sent a crew of messengers above ground, legally, into East Berlin, to alert their friends and relatives of the imminent escape. The message included a time, a place, and a password. At the time, the radios were buzzing with the news of the recent Olympics. Tokyo is dressed in her holiday vest, while the opening of the 18th modern Olympics. And so the password was Tokyo.
隧道挖掘者离开棚子后不久，他们合法地派遣了一队信使进入东柏林，通知他们的朋友和亲戚即将到来的逃亡。信息包括时间、地点和密码。当时，收音机里都在播放关于最近奥运会的新闻。东京身着节日盛装，迎接第18届现代奥运会的开幕。所以密码是“东京”。
Ralph and his friends took turns standing watch in the east, holding pistols they hope they wouldn't have to use. Back in the west, another student stood watch on the roof with a walkie talkie. The msipts and the stuff the ambulance had. of the Andruenshälter. And we had of course a very precise plan at 8.20pm there's coming a couple at 8.30pm there's coming a small family with one child. And with the Wauki-Tonki he gave us the information, oh yeah, refugee number so and so is coming. We gave the information to the front end of the tunnel in the east. That our people could prepare to open the door if their refugee comes, knocks at the door, and is saying Tokyo.
拉尔夫和他的朋友们轮流在东部守候，手里拿着他们希望不必使用的手枪。在西部，另一名学生在屋顶上拿着对讲机守候。我们当然有一个非常精确的计划，晚上8点20分会来一对夫妇，晚上8点30分会来一个带一个孩子的小家庭。通过对讲机，他给了我们信息，哦，是的，第几号难民来了。我们将信息传给东部隧道的出口。这样我们的人就可以准备好开门，如果难民来了，敲门并说“东京”。
One by one, East Germans entered the shed in the east and came out in the bakery in the west. It was after 10 p.m., Ralph was now on duty in the west. He had parked his VW bus around the corner and was going to drive the escapees to their first night of freedom. In this bus, it was so silent. Nobody talked to the other. Just sitting there like an ice block. And then I heard one whispering to his neighbor,
东德人一个接一个地进入东部的棚子，从西部的面包店出来。当时已经是晚上10点多了，拉尔夫现在在西部值班。他把大众巴士停在拐角处，准备把逃亡者送到他们自由的第一夜。在那辆车里，非常安静。没有人跟别人说话。只是像冰块一样坐在那里。然后我听到一个人对他邻居耳语，
who knows whether we are really in the west or is it not an other trap of the Shazze. I now heard that that was like an electric shock for me. These are East Germans who have just crawled to freedom through 500 feet of mud. But freedom had been out of reach for so long that they didn't believe it when they saw it. So Ralph decided to take a quick detour. He thought to himself, you go with them not the shortest way you go through Kuchosendom that they seered with their own eyes. Kuchosendom was the center of West Berlin, site of the second largest department store in Europe. It was covered with neon lights and advertisements for Coca-Cola and Marlboro, which you'd never
谁知道我们是否真的在西部，还是斯塔西的另一个陷阱。我听到这个，就像电击一样。这些是刚刚在500英尺的泥泞中爬向自由的东德人。但自由离他们太遥远了，以至于当他们看到它时，他们都不敢相信。所以拉尔夫决定绕个弯。他心想，你带他们走的路不是最短的，你带他们穿过库达姆大街，让他们亲眼看看。库达姆大街是西柏林的中心，欧洲第二大百货公司的所在地。那里到处是霓虹灯和可口可乐与万宝路的广告，你在东部永远
see in the East. Out of a sudden, they were checking, they were joking, laughing, we made it. As if it had been yesterday, it's still in my head. The tunnel operated for two nights, but among the students was at least one spy. At the end of the second night, two plain clothed policemen knocked in the apartment door in the east, tipped off by one of the spying students. They did not know the password Tokyo. One of the students standing watch opened the door.
看不到。突然之间，他们开始检查，开始开玩笑，大笑，我们成功了。就像昨天发生的一样，它仍然在我的脑海里。隧道运行了两个晚上，但学生中至少有一个间谍。第二晚结束时，两名便衣警察敲开了东部公寓的门，这是其中一名间谍学生告密的。他们不知道密码“东京”。一名守候的学生打开了门。
A moment later an East German soldier appeared, pushed his way into the building and cornered the student at the door with a Kalashnikov. Then another student fired a shot. All of them sprinted to the backyard and into the shed while the East German police fired shots after them. By the end of the night, one East German soldier was dead. The tunnel had been destroyed with grenades, and 57 people had escaped, and so the tunnel became known as tunnel 57. But the one person Ralph was trying to get out, his cousin was not among them. After the tunnel was destroyed,
片刻之后，一名东德士兵出现，挤进大楼，用卡拉什尼科夫冲锋枪把学生逼到门口。然后另一名学生开了一枪。他们全都冲向后院进入棚子，而东德警察在后面开枪。那天晚上结束时，一名东德士兵死亡。隧道被手榴弹摧毁，57人逃脱，因此这条隧道被称为“57号隧道”。但拉尔夫试图救出的那个人，他的堂兄，并不在其中。隧道被摧毁后，
East German newspapers read about Western gangsters who had tunneled in and killed one of their soldiers. The East German government installed a plaque where the escape had occurred, condemning this violent assassination. The Western students sent a letter over the wall, using balloons. It read, We speak on behalf of our group,
东德报纸报道了西方歹徒如何挖地道并杀害了他们的一名士兵。东德政府在逃亡发生的地方安装了一块牌匾，谴责这种暴力暗杀。西方学生用气球向墙那边寄了一封信。信上写着：我们代表我们的团队发言，
which over the last half a year, built a tunnel through which 57 fugitives fled, and at the entrance to which your son was shot. First, we would like to express our sincerest sympathies for so heavy a loss. They were taking responsibility for the death of this eastern soldier, but the letter went on, but the real murderer is the system that addressed the massive flight of its citizens not by removing the cause of the problem, but by building a wall, and giving the order
在过去半年里，我们建造了一条隧道，57名逃亡者通过它逃脱，而在它的入口处，你的儿子被枪杀。首先，我们要对如此沉重的损失表示最诚挚的同情。他们正在为这名东部士兵的死亡承担责任，但信中继续写道：但真正的凶手是那个系统，它不是通过消除问题的根源，而是通过筑墙来应对公民的大规模逃亡，并下达了
for Germans to shoot Germans. This story persisted for exactly 30 years, longer than the wall even existed. The story that in helping 57 people escape, Western tunnelers killed an eastern soldier. Years after the wall came down in 1989, Stasi records revealed that the eastern soldier was actually killed by friendly fire, in all the confusion. The sixth step to controlling and affecting population build a wall around information and preserve the regime's reputation. We destroyed the wall down to its roots and only a year later we said, oh what what have we done with with our own history? No clue. Only here 100 meters and there's a little bit left, and that was then preserved.
让德国人射杀德国人的命令。这个故事持续了整整30年，比柏林墙存在的时间还要长。关于西方挖掘者在帮助57人逃脱时杀害了一名东部士兵的故事。1989年柏林墙倒塌多年后，斯塔西的记录显示，那名东部士兵实际上是在混乱中死于友军误伤。控制人口流失的第六步：在信息周围筑墙，维护政权的声誉。我们把墙拆毁到根部，仅仅一年后我们说，哦，我们对自己历史做了什么？毫无头绪。只有这里100米，那里剩下一点点，那才被保存了下来。
You must understand that from situation. The Berlin, the West Berlinists, they were, let me say, they were fenced in. They were like prisoners in a in a in a free garden. There was such hate, such emotion, yeah? Turn it down, destroy it. Never, never, never, ever again. This is kind of the paradox of the past in Berlin. Destroy it, but never forget. This is a city with layers and layers of history, and yet much of it is gone.
你必须理解那种情况。柏林人，西柏林人，他们被，让我说，他们被围起来了。他们就像自由花园里的囚犯。有那么多的仇恨，那么多的情绪，对吧？把它拆掉，摧毁它。永远，永远，永远，再也不要这样了。这就是柏林过去的一种悖论。摧毁它，但永远不要忘记。这是一座有着层层历史的城市，然而大部分已经消失了。
The bunker where Hitler died, for instance, was mostly demolished. For decades, it was totally unmarked to prevent it from becoming a symbolic site for neo-nazis. The government finally installed a plaque in 2006. Even the largest remnant of the wall, the East Side Gallery, which is covered with paintings from international artists, is slated for partial demolition to make room for luxury apartments. Ralph Cobbish became a transportation engineer. He digs tunnels for a living. How many tunnels have you helped build?
例如，希特勒死亡的地堡大部分被拆除了。几十年来，它完全没有标记，以防止它成为新纳粹分子的象征性场所。政府最终在2006年安装了一块牌匾。即使是柏林墙最大的遗迹——东边画廊，上面覆盖着国际艺术家的画作，也计划部分拆除，为豪华公寓腾出空间。拉尔夫·卡比什成为了一名交通工程师。他以挖隧道为生。你参与建造了多少条隧道？
Oh, in your life. Oh, several. Subway tunnels. Korea, China, Thailand. Ralph spent his entire engineering career digging underground. When he finished school, he got a job at the German engineering company that worked on railroads. He made him an international engineering consultant on underground train systems all over the world. Taipei Railway Tunnel, Taipei Sub-a--a tunnel, essence, two metro lines, complete metro lines. What else?
哦，在你的一生中。哦，好几条。地铁隧道。韩国、中国、泰国。拉尔夫整个工程生涯都在地下挖掘。他毕业后，在一家从事铁路工作的德国工程公司找到了一份工作。他成为了一名国际工程顾问，负责世界各地的地下列车系统。台北铁路隧道，台北地铁，两条地铁线，完整的地铁线。还有什么？
These tunnels were way, way bigger than the scrappy tunnel he dug with friends under the wall. But for Roth, all those tunnels lead back, at least in his mind, to tunnel 57. Let me say it a little bit like a joke it was our apprenticeship. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Daniel A. Gross with Sam Greenspan, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. And please welcome the newest 99PI producer her name is Katie Mangle, she comes to us all the way from Chicago, from the Third Ghost International Audio Festival. If you happen to see her in the Berkeley Bowl, say hello and point her towards the good tortilla chips.
这些隧道比他和朋友在墙下挖的那条简陋隧道大得多。但对拉尔夫来说，所有这些隧道至少在他的脑海里都回到了57号隧道。让我像开玩笑一样说，那是我们的学徒期。《99%隐形》本周由丹尼尔·A·格罗斯制作，萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。请欢迎最新的99PI制作人，她的名字叫凯蒂·明格尔，她从芝加哥一路来到我们这里，来自第三届幽灵国际音频节。如果你在伯克利碗超市碰巧见到她，打个招呼，并指引她去买好吃的玉米片。
We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arksign, a brilliant collaborative architecture firm located in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars, Sam tweets at Sam listens, Avery tweets at Truffleman, Katie Mingle, the new Katie Mingle, she tweets at Katie Mingle. But we have cool pictures of tunnel 57 being made and then all the old episodes, everything you need to be a listener of 99% invisible at 99pi.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心，一家出色的协作建筑事务所Arksign的办公室里制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞我们的节目，我在推特上是@RomanMars，萨姆是@SamListens，艾弗里是@Truffleman，凯蒂·明格尔，新的凯蒂·明格尔，她在推特上是@KatieMingle。但我们有57号隧道建造时的酷照片，还有所有的旧剧集，成为《99%隐形》听众所需的一切都在99pi.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。